[Music]
humans have been making eating utensils
since prehistoric times
sterling silver flatware remained the
norm for centuries
but since the 1950s
stainless steel flatware has been the
metal of choice
stainless steel flatware is preferred by
many because it's durable and doesn't
tarnish over time
it all begins with a thick coil of wire
to make knives a heading machine cuts
the coil into blank pieces with a head
at one end
this head is called a bolster it will
connect the blade to the knife handle
a furnace softens the metal so it can be
shaped in a forging press
a series of dies progressively shape the
metal
after grinding the end of the bolster
flat the next machine welds on the tang
the tang fits inside the knife handle
an automated grinding wheel tapers the
blade thinner at the front
[Music]
a second grinding wheel scallops the
front edge
this is the knife serration
the thicker back end gives the blade
strength to withstand the pressure you
apply when cutting food
the factory uses stainless steel with a
higher nickel content for the knife
handles
it has greater corrosion resistance and
is easier to form
this is critical because the handles
often feature intricate designs
[Music]
each forged knife handle piece starts
out as half a handle
a spot welding machine tacks the two
halves together forming a complete
handle
to fuse the halves completely this
machine cuts a piece of copper-based
wire and drops it inside the hollow
handle
[Music]
a furnace melts the wire so that it
flows into the crevice between the two
halves soldering the seam thoroughly
an edging machine grinds the solder line
until it blends in with the surrounding
stainless steel
workers pour liquid cement into the
center of a carousel on which they mount
50 handles at a time
as the carousel spins the centrifugal
force shoots the cement outward filling
the handle cavities then workers insert
a blade into each one
a 10-minute soak in hot water cures the
cement
workers scrub off any excess cement that
oozed out
on the spoon line a press cuts stainless
steel into paint brush shaped pieces
then heavy rollers stretch those pieces
out thinning the end that will become
the spoon's bowl
a trim press cuts the spoon's profile
[Music]
next a machine called a coining press
punches a pattern into the handle
then forms the bowl to its rounded shape
[Music]
forks go through the same steps as
spoons before going into a press that
cuts the tines in two stages
a support bar keeps the tines from
moving while a coining press puts a
slight bend in them
the next machine slices off that bar
and stacks the finished forks
[Music]
the last stop for all the flatware is
the buffing equipment
cloth wheels polish the surface with a
liquid buffing compound until the steel
shines
[Music]
the casual flatware are now ready for
packaging
the more formal ones get dressed up with
full or partial plating in silver or
gold
[Music]
you